Oh everyone this is round one of the st.
Louis blitz tournament and already in
round one it was quite an excitement
Gurkhas part with the white pieces
playing against Sergei kurakin and Gary
decided since the king is back he's
going to bring the Kings gambit back and
okay cuz power plays
efore we have E 5 and Kasparov does go
for f4 so the Kings gambit Sergei of
course except he captures on f4 and
because power plays Knight to c3 a very
rare line of the Kings gambit which
provokes this Queen to h4 check and
Caspar plays Kings - e - of course not
g3 this would be well losing for white
and because Carter can spent around
about 45 seconds here and after some
time he decided back Queen back to the
8th and I don't think this is a this is
a line that he knew if it even ezel is a
line because like I said he did spend a
lot of time on it
we have d4 by Kasparov Knight to f6 and
now Bishop captures on f4 and Kirkham
plays Bishop to b4 and here cuz part of
plays the world a rather weird move he
plays Bishop to g5 already moving a
piece that was developed and well not
really achieving anything by this car
can place the Bishop captures on c3 we
have D captures on c3 and d6 not
allowing as part of an e5 ideas and if
you look at the position now well ok
both players have one piece developed
and the black is ready to Castle and
complete his development but White has a
King and e2 and ok he does have this
strong center but still there's a king
journey - so we have 93 by Kasparov
Carrick in castles and our Bishop
captures on f6 we have Queen captures on
f6 and Casper plays King to have to you
know he has to get his key to safety so
he will try to develop the bishop and
get the rock under the King and King to
g1 this is the this is the idea about
Cara can immediately goes for c5 since
the only good thing White has at the
moment is the center kirkin
tries to destroy it we have h3 not
allowing the Bishop to g4 and rook to e8
and now threatening that e4
and casparo plays the Queen to d3
Kirkland was Bishop to be b6 preparing
Bishop to b7 to add further pressure to
this e4 rook to e1 defending it and
Bishop to b7 and here Kasparov well it
seems that this Bishop can't really go
to e2 since this pawn is attacked so he
plays g3 and he will develop the Bishop
over G 2 so we have Knight to c6 Bishop
to g2 and I rotate the c8 and Kaspar
plays a prophylactic move a 3 and not
allowing any C capture Sundy for C
captures 94-94 ideas so we have knight
back to b8 kurakin now wants to ruin
over this Knight to d7 and then well
either to have 6:35 in the future we
have rook to e3 Knight to d7 and now
everybody thought his power would play
rook HD 1 to double up on D file but
actually plays rook to F 1 we have Queen
to e7
and now kink the g1 and okay his king is
safe now but this does a lot of Bishop
captures on e4 and the casparo actually
wanders the pawn here so Quinte - I
would have d5 and oil car cane is
preparing to push f5 so Casper is the
night to h4 to stop this and now g6 cuz
power plays Bishop to e4 he captures the
D captures on e4 and the Queen to g4 and
in this position kirkin had only eight
seconds on his clock and well cause
power plays Queen to g4 and he wants to
make something happen there there are
ideas like Knight to f5 so do Knight to
f6 by Karekin Queen to g5 not to h5 was
trying to exchange Queens Queen back to
g4 Knight to f6 Queen to g5 Kirk in
repeats night 288 5 min to g4 and well
there is a three seconds increment so
car cannon did get some time while
playing this moves but he was still
under 10 seconds and kirkin doesn't want
to draw so he doesn't repeat then he
plays Knight to g7 and okay Casper has
to go back Queen to d2 because because a
car can will was threatening f5 I would
have seek after sandy for seek after
sandy 4 and now f5 and Casper plays
Knight
- now defending that F for square we
have Queen to d6 now I think that g3
pawn and also the 8 a 3 pawn so Casper a
place C 3 and now Kerrigan snatches
another pawn so he's up 2 points now as
for plays Queen to d2 night to e6
and because part of has to try something
or else is doomed and he goes G 4 we
have Knight to g5 threatening this fork
Knight to f3 check but casparo allows
that he plays G captures on f5 and car
cane immediately jumps Knight to f3
check we have rope captures on f3
e captures on f3 and rook captures on f3
and now rope to f8 now the white a white
can capture on g6 because this rook will
fall because power goes night to h4 we
have Queen to e7 now attacking that
night and because power plays Queen to
f2 we have Queen to g5 check and Kaspar
go defense
rook to g3 and well this is looking a
bit dangerous after the Queen moves
there are some ideas about sacrificing
here on g6 so Karekin plays Queen to c1
we have a kink to g2 and now carbon
snatches another pawn rook captures in
c3 and Kasparov well Karen is still down
and tank as part of immediately plays
Knight captures and g6 and Cara can
immediately replace rook captures on g3
with check so Queen captures on g3 and
now Cara can tries everything he plays
ruptured I mean Queen to d2 and well the
idea is para wants him once Kerrigan to
capture this night and well a car cane
has to find a way playing really really
fast moves so you know he would get
enough increments to figure out a way
out of this so he'll kink to h1 kink to
d1 q g2 Queen to e2
kingi one Queen d1 engage to Quincy to
Kingi to King be one car can still tries
to find some way out of this King to h2
going to be to king h1 Queen be one king
h2 Queen a to Kim Ji Won Queen a1 King
gets to king queen bee to king which one
will be one can get
- Quincy - king h1 Queen d1 kingi -
Queen to d2 check King G 121 engage -
Queen d2 check King H 1 and here kurakin
almost lost on time as he was down to
one seconds after he played the Queen to
d1 check and well the clock was on one
second and after this they agreed to a
draw so yeah a crazy game and and well
another draw for Garry Kasparov still
without a win
except that or well that locked the
Lucky Strike he got against the laQuan
lien where he completely overlooked a
piece so yeah definitely definitely an
exciting round one and the Blitz we'll
see how the rest of the tournament goes
thank you all for watching
as usual you can check two of my
previous videos here and see you soon